it's the world's biggest Luxury company
valued at more than 400 billion dollars
with some of the industry's biggest
names under its umbrella Dior Louis
Vuitton Moet Bulgari the wayway Tiffany
it's definitely the dominant luxury
player absolutely the leader of the
luxury goods industry fashion luxury
hotels Media Outlets all Under One Roof
led by one of the world's richest people
lvmh touched the 500 billion dollar Mark
making it the first European company to
do that so how did a young man's Vision
in the 80s lead him to founding Europe's
Most Valuable company and which of his
five children will succeed him the story
of image is very interesting because
it's the story of this company but also
the story of this man Bernardo
lvmh Moet Hennessy Louis Vuitton has
soared to become one of the world's most
valuable publicly traded companies
dwarfing its Rivals Hermes as well as
caring the company that owns Gucci Yves
Saint Laurent and Balenciaga The Man
Behind The Staggering increase in value
is Bernard Arnold he gained the moniker
the wolf in the cashmere code thanks to
his high stakes take no prisoners
approach that helped him win control of
more than 70 Brands but beneath the
tough exterior was a leader with a
vision Bernard Arnold set out to build a
luxury super group that would maintain
many Brands under one company
the idea seemed foolish to many in the
industry in the 1980s how could one
company hold many competing Brands and
where would you find them all the first
stepping stone of his business history I
would say was Cristiano Cristiano was a
gem that he spotted that was part of a
textile company that was going bankrupt
but now I know knew that Joe had the
potential to become a brand that was
going to become globalized if you look
at all the luxury groups and
specifically lvmash there are ways of
strategically transforming in the
industry and for lvmh it was always
about M A sometimes aggressive M A there
has been a huge wave of brand
Acquisitions the idea being to build a
big group as fast as possible but the
biggest and boldest of lvmh's
Acquisitions was American Jeweler
Tiffany's in November 2019 at almost 16
billion dollars it Remains the luxury
industry's biggest takeover but it
wasn't without a share of drama and bmh
has said here and there that they were
not particularly interested in that
asset it so clearly this it came out as
a surprise so in 2020 covet hits and
basically people are buying fewer luxury
goods they cannot go to the stores
they're stuck at home at some point
there was a lot of tense and protracted
negotiations they threatened to go to
court and in the end they settled when
it completed in 2021 what we ended up
with was a 16 billion dollar deal
something which was four times anything
we'd really seen in the industry outside
of lvmh but if we think about where both
companies were for lvmh we think about
luxury jewelry so luxury jewelry was its
smallest category versus this scale that
it had across its of the divisions for
lvmh with Tiffany it really opened up
the Asian market more in its luxury
division lvmh's business strategy
together with a budding middle class and
Asia's fast accumulation of wealth
through the 1990s and 2000s provided the
prime conditions for the company's rapid
growth and past successes
what has happened in China in the last
20 or 30 years is you've had this
increasingly large wealthy middle or
upper class who haven't been engaged in
conspicuous consumption that's been good
for luxury goods what's so strong about
lvmh is that you have a lot of economies
of skill because they have so many
Brands they're able to negotiate better
leases with landlords when it comes to
their store locations and they not only
own fashion or jewelry Brands but they
also own Distributors and that's very
important because Sephora will not be
slashing prices on jar products because
that would be too destructive for the
brand desirability is something that
really keeps him awake at night he's got
to strike a white balance between
selling a lot of these products without
cheapening their perception in the eyes
of the consumer
in the last 10 years lvmh shares hidden
annual growth rate of about 20 percent
but the uninhibited spending on luxury
goods stands in stark contrast to
Growing global inequality making an
escalating class struggle especially
prominent and propelling and Eat the
Rich narrative
in April 2023 French protesters stormed
lvmh's Paris headquarters when President
macron tried to raise the retirement age
from 62 to 64. that very same day shares
for the company had reached a record
high
luxury today is recreating in a sense
the idea of Elites the idea of masses
the idea of a lifestyle that everybody
wants to share headwinds from a global
economic downturn are also emerging this
uh sector was priced for Perfection just
one little cloud in the sky just just
one shadow on the ball can actually
create this Market Route obviously the
consumer is key to the big luxury Brands
and the consumer is sort of reluctant to
spend right now potentially trading lvmh
it makes some sense because there is a
reopening consumer-driven trade although
that's already fizzling it would seem
lvmh is particularly exposed to
political and economic swings in Asia
with 37 of its Revenue in 2022 generated
from the region
in May billions were wiped out when a
slew of economic numbers pointed to a
fading recovery in China largely
credited for driving the industry's
rally
the Chinese economy the economic
recovery is sputtering you don't have
any concerns about China slow down at
the moment fluctuate
and finally our activities are growing
very well for many years
we're always optimism one unanswered
question remains who will lead lvmh
after Bernard Arnold now in his 70s
retires in this real-life succession
scenario the world is kept guessing
which of his five children will take the
reins as they all assume bigger roles in
lvmh
here's who's who in the Arno Clan
there's the eldest Delphine she's the
head of lvmh's second biggest fashion
brand Christian Dior
his second Antoine the most
public-facing executive among the
siblings oversees lvmh's image and
public relations from his second
marriage Bernard Arno had three more
children
Alexander's is the head of products and
communication at Tiffany Frederick hedge
the watch brand tag Hoyer and the
youngest Jean is in charge of developing
Louis Vuitton's watch catalog one of the
interesting things about the families
that they make a point of meeting once a
month at the lvmh headquarter here in
Paris where they have lunches and they
discuss everything from business to
personal matters it's a nice
relationship and working with your
family is very pleasant now being the
son in a family such as mine of course
is a great responsibility
even with his children in leadership
positions it doesn't look like our note
is ready to retire just yet in 2022 lvma
shareholders voted to list the age
limits of the CEO I.E of Bernard Arnold
from 75 to 80. I feel that that's
already
um built into share price I think that
the market overall expects at some point
he will go versus some of the peers most
of the peers lvmh is very well placed
for succession or no via his holding
company Akash owns 48 of lvmh's share
Capital but has almost 64 percent of the
Voting Rights
the ownership structure was tweaked in
2022 to ensure there are no family
retains its control over the luxury
goods conglomerate for the long term
what I think is really important today
is that once you have your whole family
set up trained to the business and to
the family house they stick together
against the enemy to anyone who's not
part of the family and who would like to
have stakes in the company the idea is
to have a family community that is going
to stick together to avoid any type of
intrusion
no no no